one of the challenges of machine
translation is that given a French
sentence there could be multiple English
translations that are equally good
translations in that French sentence so
how do you evaluate a machine
translation system if there are multiple
equally good answers unlike say image
recognition where there's one right
answer and just measure accuracy if
there are multiple great answers how do
you measure accuracy the way this is
done conventionally is with something
called the blue score so in this
optional video I want to share view I
want to give you a sense of how the blue
score works let's say you are given us
French sentence the shyest of the tapi
and you are given a reference
human-generated translation of this
which is the cat is on the mat but there
are multiple pretty good translations of
this so a different human different
person my translators as there is a cat
on the mat and both of these are
actually just fine perfectly fine
translations of the French sentence what
the blue score does is given a machine
generated translation it allows you to
automatically computer school that
measures how good is that machine
translation and the intuition is so long
as the machine generated translation is
pretty close to any of the references
provided by humans then it will get a
high blue score
blue by the way stands for bilingual
evaluation understudy
so in the theater world an understudy is
someone that learns the role of a more
senior actor so they can take over the
role of the most senior editor if
necessary and motivation for group and
motivation for blue is that whereas you
could ask human evaluators to evaluate
the machine translation system the blue
score is an understudy could be a
substitute for having humans evaluate
every output of a machine translation
system so the blue score was due to cash
old Papa nannies Salim broker's thought
wart and waiting drew this paper has
been incredibly influential and is
actually quite a reasonable and there's
actually quite a readable paper so I
encourage you to take a look if you have
time so the intuition behind the blue
score is we're going to look at the
machine generated output and see if the
types of words it generates appear in at
least one of the human generated
references and so these human generative
references would be provided as part of
the deaf set or as part of the test sent
now let's look at a somewhat extreme
example let's say that the machine
translation system abbreviating machine
translation is empty so the machine
translation of the MT outputs is dddd
dddd so this is a clearly pretty
terrible translation so one way to
measure how good the machine translation
output is is to look at each the words
in the output and see if it appears in
the references and so this would be
called a precision of the machine
translation output and in this case
there are seven words in the machine
translation output and every one of
these seven
appears in either reference 1 or
reference to right so the were--they
appears in both references so each of
these words looks like a pretty good
word to include so this will have a
precision of 7 over 7 it looks like
there's a great position so this is why
the basic precision measure of what
fraction of the words in the empty
output also appear in the references
this is not a particularly useful
measure because it seems to imply that
this empty output has very high
precision so instead what we're going to
use is a modified precision measure in
which we will give each word credit only
up to the maximum number of times it
appears in the reference sentences so in
reference 1 the were--they appears twice
in reference to that where the appears
just once so 2 is bigger than 1 and so
we're going to say that the word D gets
credit up to twice so with a modified
precision we will say that it gets a
school of two out of seven because out
of seven words will give it a two credit
or four appearing so here the
denominator is the count of the number
of times the word
D appears the seven words in total and
the numerator is the count of the number
of times the word D appears but we clip
discount and we take a max or a clip
discount at two so this gives us the
modified precision measure now so far
we've been looking at words in isolation
in the blue school you don't want to
just look at isolated worse you maybe
want to look at pairs of words as well
let's define a portion of the blue
school on by grams and by Grim's just
means pairs of words appearing next to
each other so now let's see how we could
use diagrams to define the blues
and this would just be a portion of the
final blue school and would take uni
grams or single words as well as by
grams which means pairs of words in to
count as was maybe even longer sequences
worse such as trigrams which means three
words appearing together so um let's
continue our example from before we have
the same reference 1 in reference to but
now let's say the machine translation of
the MT system has a slightly better
output the Catholic hat on the man still
no the great translation but maybe
better than the last one
so here the possible Barry Grahams are
well there's the cat gonna ignore case
and then there's caddy there's another
diagram and then there's D cats again
but I've already had that so let's skip
that and then cat on the next one and
then on the andaman so these are the
diagrams in the machine translation
output and so let's count up how many
times each of these diagrams appear the
cat appears twice caddy appears once and
the others or peer just once and then
finally let's define the clip count so
count and then subscript clip and to
define that let's take this column of
numbers but give our algorithm credit
only up to the maximum number of times
that that diagram appears in either
reference 1 or reference to so the cat
appears a maximum of once in either of
the references so with a clip that
counts of one cat V well it doesn't
appear in reference 1 or reference to so
clip that to zero cats on yep that
appears once we give it credit for once
on D appears once give that credit for
once and d-mat appears once so these are
the clipped accounts which taking all
the counts and clipping them video
reducing them to be no more than the
number of times that
appears in at least one of the
references and then finally our modified
by Graham precision will be the sum of
the count clips so that's one two three
four divided by the total number by
runners that's two three four five six
so for the six or two-thirds is the
modified precision on diagrams so let's
just formalize this a little bit further
with what we had developed with on uni
grams we define this modified precision
computed on uni grams as P subscript 1
so P sensor precision and the subscript
1 here means we're referring to uni
grams but that is defined as sum over
the uni grams so that just means sum
over the words that appear in the
machine translation output so this is
called y-hat of count clip of that uni
gram divided by sum over all uni grams
in the machine translation output of
pounds number of counts of that uni
Graham right and so this was the what we
had gotten yes I guess that's two out of
seven two slides back so the one here
refers to uni crown
meaning we're looking at single words in
isolation you can also define P n as the
end gram version instead of a unigram
foot Engram so this would be sum over
the engrams in the machine translation
output of count clip of that Engram
/ sum over n grams of the count of that
and drown
and so this these Precision's or these
modified precision schools measured on
unique grams or on by grams who if you
did on a previous slide or on try grants
which are triples of words or even
higher values of n for other engrams
this allows you to measure the degree to
which the machine translation output is
similar or maybe overlaps with the
references and one thing that you could
pray convince yourself of is if the MT
output is exactly the same as either
reference one or reference 2 then all of
these values p1 and p2 and so on they'll
all be equal to one point zero so to get
a precision or a modified precision of
one point zero you just have to be
exactly equal to one of the references
and sometimes it's possible to achieve
this even if you aren't exactly the same
as any of the references but it kind of
combined them in a way that hopefully
still results in a good translation
finally
finally let's put this together to form
the final blue school so P subscript n
is the blue school computed on n grands
only or whilst also the modified
precision computer in grams only and and
by convention to compute one number you
computes P 1 P 2 P 3 and P 4 and combine
them together using the following
formula it's going to be the average so
sum from N equals 1 to 4 of P N and
divide that by force basically taking
the average by convention the blue
school is defined as e to the this and
exponentiation is a linear operator
exponentiation is strictly monotonically
increasing operation and and then we
actually adjust this with one more
factor called d BP penalty so BP
stands for brevity penalty the details
may be on super importance but just give
you a sense it turns out that if you
output very short translations it's
easier to get high precision because
probably most of the words you appear
probably most the words the output
appear in the references so but we don't
want translations that are very short so
the BP or the brevity penalty is an
adjustment factor that penalizes
translation systems that output
translations are too short so the
formula for the brevity penalties are
following on is equal to 1 if your
machine translation system actually
outputs things that are longer than the
human generated reference outputs and
otherwise is some formula like that that
overall penalizes shorter translations
so in the details you can find in this
paper so once again earlier in this set
of causes you saw the importance of
having a single real number evaluation
metric because that allows you to try
out two ideas see which one achieves a
higher score and then you know try to
stick with the one to the chief' to
higher school so the reason the blue
school was revolutionary for machine
translation was because this gave a
pretty good by no means perfect but
pretty good single real number
evaluation metric and so that
accelerated to the progress of the
entire field of machine translation I
hope this video gave you a sense of how
the blue school works in practice few
people would implement a blue school
from scratch their open source
implementations you can download and
just use the evaluate your own system
but today blue school is use evaluate
many systems that generate text such as
machine translation systems as well as
the example I showed briefly earlier of
image captioning systems where you would
have a system of a neural network
generated image
and then use the blue skull to see how
much that overlaps work may be a
reference caption or multiple reference
captions that were generated by people
so the blue score is a useful single
real number evaluation metric to use
whenever you want your algorithm to
generate a piece of text and you want to
see whether it has similar meaning as a
reference piece of text generated by
humans this is not used for speech
recognition because of speech
recognition there's usually you know one
ground truthing you just use other
measures to see if you've got the speech
transcription on pretty much exactly
where from where correct but for things
like image captioning multiple captions
for a picture it could be about equally
good or for machine translation there
are multiple translations about equally
good the blue score gives you a way to
evaluate that automatically and
therefore speed up your alfred big
development so with that I hope you have
a sense of how the blue score works